[Music]
all right
for some reason it fell
the line fell
it was you you broke it yeah
you broke it
i don't know let's you know the
connection's mostly good it just seems
like it's very every now and then it was
just kind of
rad
what you doing down there pokey pants oh
pookie came in to visit yeah she's like
playing with them you playing with stuff
come here oh no no no she's like what
what what
what
come here you want to be on the show
come on everybody everybody wants to see
you no no no no thank you yeah
oh don't you want to come up here you
shy want to come up here yeah come see
daddy come see dad he's like no i know
yeah i don't know where i got cut off i
was just talking about how
the connection was abducted by aliens
yeah yeah
the aliens they hear what i'm talking
about
and they're like
we can't have this dude talking like
this and they shut that [ __ ] off
i really i don't think that's what it is
because honestly it went red when we
were talking about
thanksgiving leftovers it went red when
we were talking about candy it went red
when we were talking about all kind of
random [ __ ] yeah so
you know
i know you like to think you're like
like what you say like everybody's
listening but it's a really it's not
saying everybody i think it's i think
it's i think it's algorithms maybe i
think it's [ __ ] computer ai there's
too many buzzwords come up and they go
nah he must not be talking about
anything good and they start [ __ ]
they're talking he's talking bad about
us so they start slowing it down
giving you warnings and then they shut
your ass off
they want me talking about those cities
falling apart
because of the technology you don't need
them
see
ilsa says the aliens want to abduct your
thanksgiving leftovers yeah i know i'm
going to give them a [ __ ] thing they
better not i'm going to get something
yeah i'm about ready to go down there i
mean no we got to do we got to do the
show and i'm going man we got
thanksgiving leftovers down there i know
but they're still going to be there
later and no one's gonna like the aliens
aren't gonna come and eat them it's fine
i gotta go down there and put them in
the refrigerator i guess
well you can if you want okay
i mean i'm gonna eat some later like
after the show i mean i had some for
lunch
you know we'll be down with show
probably over in about an hour anyway
that's what i'm saying so might as well
just leave them out
okay
well then what are you worried about
about them [ __ ] going bad i don't
think they will go bad everything's
nothing's gonna go bad yeah it's fine
yeah no one it's nice and cool in here
yeah there's no germs yeah the cats
don't want it so they're not going to
jump up there and eat it yeah
although i will savor i will say that
yesterday no not yesterday the day
before yesterday day before thanksgiving
uh because there was so much cooking
activity going on in the kitchen we were
like well
let's you know get take out so we got
chinese food yeah and for whatever
reason like i got egg foo young
and pookie was into that [ __ ]
she didn't eat any of it but she kept
like i was trying to eat it like while i
was working at the same time like at my
desk and she jumped up on the desk and
kept like she kept sticking her face in
the
in the carton she's like sticking her
face what you got there what you got
there what you got there and i'm like
it's that and she's like can i eat it
and she's like no gimme gimme gimme but
she does that to my coffee mug too and
she doesn't like coffee oh victor has
finally showed up
yeah we did like two
what was it two hours i think we did two
hours before
but then like the stream crashed again
so we had to like start again
it went red when you said holiday yeah
camp that says i made a real roof for
the first time from my grave is awesome
dry roasted turkey wings with
onion and garlic celery and then add
chicken broth reduce it cook it for
about three hours to add to carol roo
yeah
um
yeah roo's good
now you take now you know how to [ __ ]
with roo
now you need to make gumbo
you need roux
and you need something called gumbo
filet
filet's a little spice mix you can get
about that big around but that's all a
little glass bottle thank you victor
thank you very much says i missed y'all
thank you we missed you too we wondered
where you were you can get gumbo filet
at the grocery store villa filet is like
sassafras yeah leaves essentially it's
all grounded grounded espresso yeah it's
white it's in your white excuse me it's
green powder
and uh xadarans make some
you'll find it but you need that and rue
and then uh
get you some shrimp or get your sausage
slice it or chicken
mcgumbo
okra you gotta pre-cook that okra get
all the damn cornstarch and all the
slime out of it first and then put it in
there and then slime yeah it releases
all kind of slime
it does yeah you gotta cook it pre-cook
it first and then separate the two and
then
put that in the gumbo
and serve it over rice or put rice in it
so
kind of like a
louisiana
french
african
kind of dish it's good real good
camp guy said i can get sassafras in the
woods right outside my door
yeah sassafras grows wild yeah but
that's not gumbo in the south a lot but
like i said that's
that's what it's made from though yeah
yeah but it's mostly there's bay in
there bay leaves and all kinds of stuff
and you put bay in it also
um no but you need filet
camp guys said i like slimy boiled okra
whole pods slide right down
i'm not a big okr fan i like it in
gumbo
but
i don't know i don't really like it that
much otherwise
mr robotta says tom jenny how's the
eggnog we haven't got any eggnog yet
this year we haven't done it yet this
year it's a little early
it's so fattening i'm not i hate to say
i'm not like a big fan of eggnog
yeah however i did order all of my um
mocha mint like my peppermint cappuccino
mixes
for this year i always get like at
amazon i was they have like a pack
of six of them like the mixes because i
always like to have
minty cappuccino this time of year
gumbo filet it says file on it but it's
felix no there's an accent over the e
clearly yes there is i do not see it
okay yeah duh don't tell me no
no
yeah well because you always just assume
i'm wrong
even though it's even though it's right
there i didn't see the accent yeah it's
right there well on the printed part it
didn't have the accent on the printed
part
well they probably don't know how to
make like an accented e on the [ __ ]
yeah honestly to be fair like on a pc
i'm not sure how to do like accented
ease or like umlauts or anything i know
how to do it on a mac but i can't do
it's easier on a mac than it is on a pc
gotta say
uh yeah elsa says fried okra is where
it's at yeah
yeah if you're gonna like bread and fry
it yeah then then i'm on board
picture says i love eggnog
i like i said i like it in small doses
it'd have to be kind of like
a glass that big with some rum in it and
then i'll drink it but
i think
ice cream i like [ __ ] i like eggnog
everything
yeah tom's a big eggnog
it's a little much for me it's just he's
a little rich i don't know
tila says it feels like saturday today
that's what i thought
all day today i kind of felt like it was
saturday because i just like farted
around and did nothing yesterday
yesterday we just ate
watched turkey day marathon and i read
three quarters of a book
so
but it was nice like not really having
to do anything
it's the nice thing about holidays is
that
i know that no one's gonna bother me
you know what i mean because everyone
else is off too so it's not like i'm
gonna get some email going like hey i
need this flyer or i need this that or
the other thing so you know it's nice to
just kind of like chill out and not
worry about it
camp guy says okra is one of the easier
most prolific vegetables you can grow
keeps on putting on pods in the hot
summer sun
yeah and victor said bluebell came out
with eggnog ice cream did we get that
one year
yeah did you get that yeah yeah
i didn't i don't know if i ate any of it
but i think we got some bluebell is the
best ice cream
yeah it is it is pretty good it's pretty
damn good ice cream of the south
the rocky road is [ __ ] unbelievable
all of it's good
all even the vanilla and it [ __ ]
stretches
and that snaps oh [ __ ] so good
yeah
even the damn
pistachio is good
the
neapolitan is good it's all good [ __ ]
there's not ice cream in a long time
yeah their head there's not a bad
bluebell they're all good
like i said i'm gonna have ice cream i
want some [ __ ] crunchy ass [ __ ] in
there yeah i want some mint chocolate
chip
butter pecan or
something's got nuts in it
or something or i like uh i like coffee
ice cream but it's gotta have like
chunks of chocolate or something like
that in it dermot says i didn't know
this actually
german says okra is called ladyfingers
here in the uk weird huh really
ladyfingers here is a completely
different thing many fingers is a
firecracker here well no ladyfingers are
like uh that dessert cookies they're
kind of like cookies yeah twinkie-ish
kind of they're not twinkies but they're
kind of that shape they're twinkies
ladyfinger is also a little tiny
firecracker
don't you remember those yeah i remember
those but i don't i don't think that's
the most common nomenclature mississippi
well down south i'm talking about in
america as a whole yeah ladyfingers is
more like a dessert
like a little cake like a long like a
twinkie but smaller and you kind of like
soak them in liqueur and
yeah i guess yeah
trader joe's uh says tila had an eggnog
liqueur i'm sure that was probably good
danny rolling ghostface asked what's tom
and jenny's favorite episode of the show
a haunting
haunting a summer win
yeah i knew you were gonna say that yeah
that was a good one demon child demon
chad was good too yeah man said i could
yeah
um why would you do that to the kitty
yeah where's that raccoon that was that
was actually somewhere
i'm trying to think of what else
the bobby mackey one was good yeah it's
okay
um
what was that there was a lot of good
ones actually first and second season
yeah three is pretty good because like i
said i bought you the first four seasons
yeah on dvd like the box set
they still have them they still make
those
yeah as far as i know yeah i don't know
if you can get them on dvd probably not
no um because i checked one year yeah i
don't think after season
six
or seven i think that was the last
because i think i bought you a couple
like
um yeah individually yeah yeah um but
then after that they just went all
online they're like yeah they don't they
don't make physical ones anymore right
well they didn't have enough money
wrapped up in the into that anymore yeah
it kind of went downhill
mr roboto asked uh jenny what's your
favorite coffee alcohol other than
bailey's
a long time ago they used to make
a coffee
vodka
do you remember what brand that was it
wasn't pinnacle
it was kind of its own thing i used to
get it at venue 13 and it was so good
that i mean it tasted like vodka but it
still tasted like very very strongly of
coffee and it was like really really
dark i don't remember um and i can't
remember what the brand name of it was
it wasn't pinnacle it wasn't one of the
ones that you would think of when you
thought of like flavored vodkas but it
was really really nice and you could
drink it straight that's how good it was
you didn't have to mix it with anything
but god damn it i can't remember what
the [ __ ] name of it is but yeah i
mean bailey's is good too just gonna say
uh and then tila asked what's everyone's
favorite twilight zone episode oh man
ooh
the one the kid [ __ ] wishing people
out to the corn cornfield that was the
[ __ ] yeah it's a i think it's called
it's a good life it's a good life yeah
um i've always been partial to eye the
beholder
um which is the the one about all the
people that look like pigs
and the the woman that has like is
getting plastic surgery yeah and also
the one with william shatner where he
goes to that town and like uh
wishes on that kind of thing in the
diner with the devil head on it what the
[ __ ] is the name of that thing it was
william shatner yeah i think william
shatner remember he was flying in the
airplane and scene well yeah that's
that's a good one too that just seems
like a yeah yeah that was twilight zone
wouldn't it
i'm pretty sure didn't richard matheson
write that i kind of feel like richard
madison and then then we're talking
about night gallery
ooh night gallery
one where the girl was beating the
little girl this little girl little boy
is beating up on the damn monster
[ __ ] then eventually it came in ater
i mean i don't remember that one
yeah we just rewatched all the twilight
zones a couple years ago i gotta see him
again because i think well i don't know
if they're still on netflix but they
were like a year or two yeah what about
the one where that old [ __ ] dude had
damn arthritis it was one it was so
what's this and then you guys go out
there dig watch 10 paces and dig and
you'll find a big surprise for that and
they dig it you [ __ ]
the bad boys went and they dug that [ __ ]
up there's a cough and he opens up he
comes out and goes
surprised
[Laughter]
and there was also cool air
that was an h that's an hp love story
that one was in it it's pretty good
yeah that's that's a pretty famous story
that's been adapted a bunch of times
yeah
but uh yeah victor said remember the one
about the kid that was like a god made
his sister's mouth disappear yeah that
was a yeah that was it's a good life
yeah they actually remade that one for
the twilight zone movie in the 80s
uh they changed it a little bit from the
original story yeah um
but yeah they kind of gave it a little
bit of a
promising ending which i didn't that
wasn't good they should have left that
[ __ ] it was a [ __ ] nightmare of what
it was
i mean it was still kind of [ __ ] up at
the end because i mean he basically made
the whole entire world disappear
except for him and that woman
and she said they could leave i thought
they left together well she was just
kind of telling him well we need to like
get control of this [ __ ] that you can do
because i mean if he could wish the
whole world gone he could wish it back
too like it wasn't you know irreversible
so you know
he said yeah i remember it from the
movie yeah the one from the original
twilight zone episode was a lot
a lot different it was the same basic
concept
but
it didn't as far as i remember the one
from the i haven't seen a long time but
the one from the original twilight zone
episode
it didn't really
resolve did it because i
mean no they were trapped in it well
yeah because it wouldn't i mean if if
you if there was actually a kid that had
that power that could just like wish
anything into or out of existence
you'd kind of be [ __ ] everyone would
be [ __ ] and there wouldn't really be
anything you could do about it so i kind
of feel like that's what happened in
that whereas like the movie one
they kind of gave it a little bit more
of an ending in the sense that yeah he
wished the entire world away because he
got all pissed off about something
but
he liked that one that teacher that he
met enough
that maybe she could like reign that
[ __ ] in at some point i mean i like from
what i remember the original one i may
be wrong but from what i remember they
had one guy who was complaining about
[ __ ] why doesn't somebody just kill
the kids people behind hey why is this
like why is everybody just cowards and
i'm like why don't you kill the kid
remember that yeah
he didn't kill the kid that's true
yeah it's really easy to like tell other
people yeah yeah why doesn't somebody
else just kill the kids but it's a whole
town of cowards and they're like yeah
but you're not killing the kid walk up
behind a kid and kill him
which i guess is kind of like
it's kind of like with dictators a
dictator can [ __ ] do all kinds of
[ __ ] in the country and [ __ ] other
people why didn't somebody kill them
well why don't you kill them
you know they don't do it
well it's it's easy to like talk about
yeah it's quite different to like
actually they want to get in trouble do
you
yeah
well it's funny because i was a movie
that i'm going to be reviewing in a
couple of weeks which is a british movie
called the children
and it's kind of like a similar premise
where these kids kind of go homicidal
and it's kind of playing on the idea
that if your kid went homicidal
you wouldn't one you wouldn't really
believe it at first and two could you
really kill them if you had to
this little innocent looking child
um
and i kind of liked that the movie
played with that and that was kind of
like the same thing that they were going
with with the twilight zone thing it's
like could you really
yeah this kid was like a dick and he was
horrible and everything but could you
really kill
a little kid
not a lot of people could
you know
mr obata says he'd rather go to the
cornfield at least he'd be free yeah
he'd be the cornfield as a
jack-in-the-box though
yeah my thing was like it really didn't
seem that fun in the cornfield and
honestly in the in the one that they did
in the 80s movie
the twilight zone movie that john landis
uh well he john leaders didn't do that
part he did the one where vic morrow got
killed um i can't who directed the that
segment of the twilight zone movie that
one because it was all different
directors i can't remember
but um in that one
they didn't mention a cornfield he just
basically just like wished you away like
his sister one of his sisters he wished
her into a cartoon
and then she got eaten by a cartoon
dragon
that says in the movie though right that
was in the movie that's what i just said
so i so he just like wished people into
like non-existence kind of or into like
limbo
you know what i mean so i i mean i guess
back in the old days everything like out
into the cornfield that was kind of like
limbo but in the 80s they were just kind
of like it was like actual limbo so you
just be like there'd be nothingness
and honestly like he wished his whole
family away and like the the teacher
asked what he had done with them and he
said i gave them what they wanted like
to be away from me yeah so he just like
wished them into
a nowhere
all right so i guess they're all just
kind of like wandering around in some
empty [ __ ] another good one that
nobody remembers is the one where the
guy [ __ ] can't find his daughter and
he hears her [ __ ] calling through oh
that's a good one too so then he gets
his buddy who's a physicist to come out
remember and he goes yeah and figure out
that she has slipped into a parallel
dimension like through the wall
and they're trying to figure out how
they're going to get her out that was a
[ __ ] really good that was a good one
it was nothing but just dealing with the
here and now because it must start from
here to here oh yeah he's doing a whole
it must be what they call a parallel
dimension they end up getting trying to
get rather than they send the dog in
there yeah the dog well the dog does the
dog go in accidentally i thought the dog
went an accident that dog had a rope on
it i can't remember it but i think they
sent the dog in there they're gonna go
get her boy if i can he went through the
wall
and she grabbed all the dog and they
pulled the dog out and got her up got
her and the dog out that's how i
remembered it and they'd hear her all in
kind of weird every time she moves this
way it's it's two it's a foot in her
dimension but over here it's 20 feet
remember that yeah yeah that's pretty so
good i'd like to see that one again well
see i was i always like a good story
where and this is why i think i talked
about this on my house of leaves review
you always like a good thing where
uh your internal like architecture is
not how it appears that's always like
really unsettling you know what's weird
is that that episode looking at it now
that reminds me a lot of what it was
like at mammoth mountain that felt like
that type of situation yeah that it was
just something paranormal where you
thought you could fall through the wall
no that's something paranormal that
[ __ ] things were being moved you
couldn't see it and it was something in
another dimension just like that
remember how they were trying to figure
it out that's what it was like yeah
yeah
man i wish that [ __ ] was [ __ ] kicked
back off against with enough frequency
so you you'd trip out you you'd lose
your [ __ ] mind i wouldn't it was like
that
but yeah get it to kick off again
it's all you doing it yeah i gotta
[ __ ] it takes time to [ __ ] get
that [ __ ] spun up just chill out and get
it all [ __ ] do we need to have like a
seance or something nah if i practically
pin up like a [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] yeah yeah we'll see
how that goes i had to get real [ __ ]
agitated
well that shouldn't be too hard
no
danny rowling ghostface says that
macaulay culkin film the good sun is a
good dark thriller yes it is i agree
where the mother has to choose to save
her bad son or her good nephew and drop
one off a cliff yeah i remember that
honestly i kind of feel like that's a
really good thing to explore and like i
said i'm going to talk about this when i
review the movie the children because i
just rewatched it today
and that kind of uh goes there going to
say
because that's kind of like a sensitive
topic what happens
when your kids turn into like murderous
little [ __ ]
and um you you kind of have to like kill
him to save yourself
and it kind of goes against every
you know human instinct yeah to do that
uh and the kids are cute and all this
other kind of [ __ ] so but
also they might stab you
you know i i kind of feel like that's
why killer kids are like a big thing in
horror
because
it's such a horrifying idea of like your
own kids what about that
people [ __ ] um adopted that
i don't know it was a croatian
little girl
and it turned out it wasn't a little
girl orphan yeah that's a movie no it
was real
well it was a movie called orphan no she
okay never mind no i'm just saying yeah
i don't know if it happened in real life
but that was that was a movie that's a
real-life case where
just people um
it happened a long time ago
they adopted this little i think she was
croatian
girl
and they thought she was about like
seven
but she wasn't
she's more like about
15 16 17.
and they kept her for a long time she
was in her 20s
and
yeah somebody in the audience might
remember
she was just doing weird [ __ ] and she
ran out on her own and
was doing weird sexual [ __ ]
and it turned out she was never really a
child i think she was like [ __ ] i
don't i think she might have been almost
an adult when they adopted her but she
didn't look like a
little kid she just had some medical
problems she wasn't growing
her teeth were kind of [ __ ] up but
other than that she looked
i mean i don't know if it was based on a
real story or not but there was a movie
called orphan that was exactly that that
was
this couple and their kid died and they
adopted another girl and they thought
she was
11. or something like that but it turned
out she was like 30.
uh but she had some kind of like medical
disorders yeah it's the same she was
like hitting on the dad we're talking
about the same one it's the same thing
well like i said that's a movie called
orphan dude that was based on something
that really happened maybe i'm gonna
show it to you right now
do do
do some people are bringing up magic
with anthony hopkins i actually did a
review of that
a couple months ago i think yeah i love
that movie too
if you love um
there is creepy ventriloquist dummies
claims that adopt a daughter is actually
a 22 year old
what year is that from though
well this they're talking about in 2019
hold on let me see if i can find it i
mean
right there i mean the movie came out
ukrainian daughter 9 was 22 it had
dwarfism
okay
she tried to kill us
yeah but
the movie came out way before this story
though all right so i kind of and that's
from the daily mail so i kind of feel
like they probably just made it up no
[Laughter]
no they were they were whole
the movie came out in 20 or 2007.
i want to say it was 2007. something
like that it was a while back it's a
good movie though
i mean i don't know i don't know if it's
based on a real story but that story was
it's not old the movie came out like a
long time before that story came out
and it kind of just sounds like there
no it really did happen i saw
i saw a bunch of programs on it
victor said that happened after the
movie came out it happened that's her
right there
that's her right there
i'll do that you guys you guys
they had it on damn television programs
the courts were involved in it and
everything that is the case that really
did happen
yeah the case didn't i think it happened
in england yeah it did well i'm just
saying the case happened after the movie
came out okay because the movie came out
in 2009 thank you tila i thought it was
2007 but it was 2009.
and her name was uh natalya grace of
ukraine
yeah she was on dr phil
yeah
at dr phil tell you grace are you i
don't know that [ __ ]
it actually is the indiana couple they
were scammed into adopting an adult
ukrainian with dwarfism now yeah i
remember kind of hearing about that but
then i was just kind of like wait did
they get that idea from orphan or did
that really happen because like i said
the movie came out like before and it
was like a pretty well-known movie so i
didn't know like
i didn't know if they were just making
it up
or it was just or if it was one of those
stories that just went around like is an
urban legend kind of thing
yeah victor said it was here and her
adoptive parents got her an apartment
and moved to canada without her yeah
yeah
that sounds right i think they did like
hey you're a grown-up bye that's right
it was an adult posing as a [ __ ]
child
which like i said that's that's why i
was suspicious because i'm like that's
exactly like the plot of orphans there's
the code of appeals in indiana and
everything that's exactly like the plot
of orphan yeah
that's exactly what happened no that did
happen and she was even
now wasn't i haven't seen orphan in a
few years but wasn't she supposed to be
from i didn't think she was like eastern
european or something or maybe not maybe
she wasn't i can't remember
she's a ukrainian one girl
woman she's
but she was posing as a child yeah
that's it like i said that's the same
thing and i guess she came out of some
that's her right there
see
it's right there
yeah he's on dr phil [ __ ] dr phil dr
phil yeah that's her
even though that douche was still around
she did look like a little baby though
i'm totally not a grownup i'm totally
not a grown-up you could get away with
all kind of you can get away with all
kinds of stuff
i mean not gonna lie if i was like 30
years old and still look like a
seven-year-old i might try to pull that
scam
i'm not proud
i don't think it was just her
because there was had there been a whole
agency involved in it
so mr about any what some ukrainian
agency soldier or something
mr abadi says evil children just give
them bourbon yeah
i mean you know
i like that i like those killer kid
movies
yeah dermot said she was russian in the
movie that's what i thought yeah i
thought she was something like that
i thought she was something like that
but yeah that's why but you can see why
i was skeptical because i was like yeah
that's that's a new story and that's
that movie came out like a long time ago
so
well anything can happen in the world
and that was the [ __ ] somebody tried
that
that's what i'm saying but maybe that's
where maybe that's where she got the
idea maybe she got the idea from the
movie probably not
probably not i don't think that
i think it was just somebody said this
looks like a little girl the seller
you know and they sold her that way
she's like yeah i get some free [ __ ]
i get out of ukraine they said she was a
sociopath [ __ ] psycho
just like in the movie yeah she's going
after the husband she had to kill him
just like in the movie yeah
that happened in the movie too you
should watch the movie it's good yeah
it's good but yeah it's the same it's
essentially the same story
uh ilsa says i was listening to the
october country by ray bradbury yeah
that's an excellent book on audiobook
one story was about this angry dwarf
yeah
that's a yeah that's a really good book
uh badass domain says mikey is a good
killer kid movie
i remember that
oh
i saw that but it was like a long time
ago i'm all into the like the killer kid
movies well like i said that's why i
wanted to kind of highlight like i said
that the review of it won't go up for a
few weeks
but i watched the movie today so i'm
probably gonna like record it this
weekend sometime
um it's a british movie it came out in
2008 i want to say it's called the
children
and it's about killer kids but it's like
not funny at all it's like very
realistic it's very gory and it's
honestly
if you don't mind kids getting killed in
like horrible ways
being like smooshed by cars and
impaled by glass and stuff like that
then
this is your movie
just gonna say it goes there
a lot of american movies would not
i kind of feel like a lot of american
movies would sort of shy away from
they'll do killer kid movies but they
kind of like they kind of pull their
punches a little bit they're like well
it's a kid we don't really want to
you know what i mean we don't really
want to see them getting [ __ ] up or
getting killed or anything not this
movie is like no [ __ ] it
the kids are getting [ __ ] [ __ ] up
in all kind of ways and uh yeah it's
pretty it's it's actually like really
really good and it's weird it's one of
those movies that this is what i'm
saying about to be
i kind of feel like people have this
perception horror fans have this
perception that 2b
because it's free with commercials
they're like oh well all the horror
movies on there are probably like sucky
not so
yes probably like 75 80 percent of the
movies on there are probably sucky but
there's a lot of really good [ __ ] on
there too so you really got to watch and
this movie is for free on there and it's
really really good so who said they were
talking about the movie it's alive
last night over there with the with the
killer the baby yeah that was a good
movie honestly i love i love it's alive
i i hadn't seen it
i never saw it when it came out but i
heard had friends at school i think it's
in the third grade when that [ __ ] came
out talking about they saw it somehow
that's because in california there was
always a way
and like it was trickling down what was
happening the baby running around
killing people it was a [ __ ] mutant
baby
and i was like
i remember being kind of confused well
it's a monster or it's a baby this is no
it's both
the baby is it's a baby monster and i'm
like the baby's a monster and i was
trying to grab my head around this
yeah it was boring there was something
wrong with it and it came out it was
like a monster
and it was killing people and it was
biting them and it was flying it it's it
could kill it it could kill an adult so
i can kill a big person they're like
yeah it could kill a big breath so you
know how it is when you're a kid
yeah how did it do that you know i had
everything i had teeth they had claws
they could fly you know just [ __ ] like
that
that was freaking out man this is and it
went down the storm drains where the
[ __ ] ants were from them and i was
like what
it was blowing my [ __ ] and it turned
out that that it was it was true
that did happen
it just didn't happen in that order i
don't think did it remember it
remember it went down into the storm
drains yeah it's been a while since i've
seen it but yeah if i remember correctly
without storm drains
they made at least one sequel to that
yeah there might have been more there
was another sequel
there was a sequel there was a sequel
yeah oh man got to see that
yeah i've seen it i don't remember much
about it i remember like the
you know the original one is the most
memorable
uh from what i remember how long ago was
it that we saw that
four years five years probably i
remember liking it yeah it's good yeah
that's pretty good it's good yeah
it was a low budget movie but it had a
good pace to it i remember having a good
edit and come on killer baby yeah
dude dude knocked her up and [ __ ]
baby popped out it was killing [ __ ]
how could you not love that yeah and i
don't remember how that happened did it
have something to do with something in
the water mercury or something in the
water oh [ __ ] i don't remember now
atomic radiation in the water something
like that i don't remember what did it
tila probably remember she saw it she
saw well i can't wait a minute i might
be confusing that because i know that
there was another movie that came out in
the 70s
that was like an environmental horror
like oh we're mutating all the animals
type of thing and
yeah i think it was prophecy that had
like some [ __ ] me and babies mutant
bear no yeah so i kind of feel like yeah
maybe i'm getting yeah [ __ ] the mama
gave birth to a [ __ ] mutant bear
and a bear came out and killed the mama
and it got [ __ ] big you remember that
yeah
and it was a bipedal bear it could stand
up
well i mean bears bears can stand up but
you know yeah but this was just a man in
a suit
[Laughter]
we're saying he's mutated because it's
just a dude and a costume that's how
we're explaining it it looked good
though
[Laughter]
when you weren't looking at it for very
long you know because it couldn't move
real well from what i remember like if
your eyesight wasn't good
if you're like some mr magoo [ __ ] you're
really looking at it but formed ass
looking bear without any hair on it
standing up on its back legs and big all
these [ __ ] teeth
didn't he bite somebody didn't somebody
bite somebody's head off in that yeah it
had to have donald trump i remember one
time there was somebody trying to run
away hopping in the damn sleeping bag
and it goes bam and hits and the
feathers go flying and the [ __ ]
remember that and the [ __ ] sleeping
bag goes flying it hits the [ __ ] tree
goes
and it's like the man breaks
man that was like friday the 13th part
seven yeah where jason picks up the
person in the sleeping bag and goes
whack against the tree yeah i guess just
like that one of my favorite kills from
the freddie 13 series
in prophecy the [ __ ] bear just
[ __ ] batted it like that see now i
want to see that again i haven't seen
that a long time honestly
all i remember of that one is what
stephen king talked about because he
talked about that extensively for some
weird reason in dance macabre yeah okay
the [ __ ] tina's got it she goes they
they briefly show the baby humongous
eyes with claws and fangs yeah it's a
cool like a baby the mother harbored him
without the father knowing the baby was
killing the milk man and [ __ ] yeah
experimental fertility treatments
oh that's that's right that's right
i had totally that's right was that that
was larry cohen i was that larry cohen
yeah i kind of feel like you got to see
that [ __ ] again that was a good one
you could probably it's almost almost
kind of like along the lines of [ __ ]
uh the brood the brood kind of was
another one little killer babies woman
hatched a whole [ __ ] a whole brood of
these little she's like in there like
boogie and like licking them and stuff
yeah she's like the [ __ ]
aunt of all these little [ __ ] aunt
children
they don't they're not male or female
they're they're they're not even they
don't remember that they don't have
they're genderless
and they're [ __ ] um they're just
created by her mind she can get her
[ __ ] eggs to [ __ ] start
fertilizing themselves and [ __ ]
reproducing well it's like period but it
comes out alive and it's [ __ ] and
then they obey her [ __ ] herself well
they're
they're rage babies yeah they're rage
babies baby that's like a
personification of her yeah but there's
like a psychic force that is getting her
to impregnate her own eggs
and they're bad like the way i wish i
thought of that that's a brilliant idea
that i'll add i love it and they come
out and they're [ __ ] embodiments of
all her [ __ ] anger and [ __ ] and i
think she was con when she kind of
commanded them with psychic abilities
yeah i kind of thought that it was sort
of like a hive mindset
was it not i think so i thought i
thought so do you have all them bugging
babies maybe running around in their pjs
[ __ ] killing people they're little
onesies yeah little onesies little
little footy pajamas little foodie
pajamas with a little jacket on can you
imagine how horrifying that would be if
you had like a bunch of kids and like
they're in their little feety pajamas
and they were just like coming at you
going hey mother yeah and they weren't
[ __ ] they were children but not
really
not they weren't
fully human when you think about it well
like i said i kind of feel like that's
why that's a whole like little sub genre
of horror is because
people that are parents i'm like i can't
relate i'm just cat parent but
if you had human children
what would happen
and i'm sure like a lot of the people
that wrote this like stephen king people
like that that have written stuff like
this like had children of their own what
would happen
if your children
suddenly turned into like monsters they
like turned on you and it kind of became
um
a situation where you had to kill them
or they would kill you could you do it
and that's like
like from a parent's point of view
that's probably like one of the worst
things that you could think of you know
what i mean jesus said that baby was
born and it killed the whole medical it
did that's like that's honestly that's
like the main scene that i remember was
in like the birthing room like the
baby's born it just kills every [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] room
uh now taylor did i get it right didn't
they end up down in the damn california
store storm drains
in the [ __ ] in the old [ __ ] l.a
river
i think they did
tila also brings up the bad seed
from the 50s oh yeah uh also a good that
was actually based on a book yeah and
like i said i like the killer kid movies
that one was actually really really good
that's a that's a classic
uh mr roboto says 2b is interesting
to be is
well the thing about tubey is that it's
free
uh because there's ads so
it's gonna be kind of like
70
crap
but maybe even 80 crap
but you really got to look through the
[ __ ] they have a lot
a lot of horror content yeah so there's
a lot of [ __ ] you have to like wade
through
but i know there's like a [ __ ] ton of
like really really bad [ __ ]
ouija shark level stuff on there yeah
but
there's a lot of really good [ __ ] on
there too so don't like write it off
yeah tina says that they cornered him
down there to [ __ ] storm drains the
father was trying to save him yeah i got
to see that again she says she's never
seen the brood man if you haven't seen
the brood that's oh i love the brood
yeah that's good that's right up there
with damn video jerome
yes david cronenberg yeah cronenberg
movies man you got to see all day yeah
video drone was a [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
whoa
blew my [ __ ] mind
see i'm just like i don't know like as a
creative person i'm really i've always
been really jealous of people like david
lynch david cronenberg stuff like that
i'm like how do you like guys think of
like weird [ __ ] like that i don't know
like i think of weird [ __ ] but
i don't know i feel like i haven't
thought of anything that weird she says
they'd be a good one the brood and us
alive and and it's allowed to be a good
double future it probably would be
honestly watch those two together
because it's like oh it's the killer
kids double feature
i'm into it
and then in the brood
man it's got that [ __ ] creepy ass
british dude that's always on the edge
of [ __ ] whip in your ass [ __ ]
what's that oliver oliver reed yeah he
he's the one [ __ ]
he's one of the main characters oliver
reed oliver reed scared the [ __ ] out of
me as a kid him and michael kay
both of those dudes i can see that
though because those two guys
they're great actors but
they did have that thing where it's just
kind of like i'm about two seconds yeah
i'm just like losing my [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
losing my [ __ ] they were just like they
were like abusive fathers or something
they feel like that's your daddy and
he's going to [ __ ] beat you up that's
what it felt like and [ __ ] this is
you know what i'm talking about
someone's like going back to some
childhood trauma or something no
no i could just [ __ ] tell that that's
what that [ __ ] was about that is kind of
how they came that's how they came
and have you ever seen was it uh
god damn it was it women in love that
had oliver reed and the other dude like
wrestling naked in front of the
fireplace
yeah they did that in that movie yeah
that was women in love right am i
remembering that yeah
oliver reed was [ __ ]
he was a good actor okay and uh he you
know these are [ __ ] bert's offerings
[ __ ] come on
he was a a [ __ ] trained british actor
of the theater you know [ __ ]
shakespeare and [ __ ]
and uh and all the other kinds of
[ __ ] 1960s style [ __ ] theater
which was real [ __ ] you know
loopy [ __ ] hippie [ __ ] you know what
i mean he was into that [ __ ] too but he
loved booze and he liked making money
and he liked winning i also love booze
yeah and and to have booze and women you
have to act see
that's how that works that's how that
works
sometimes sometimes in your acting in
your acting career you're going to have
to wrestle other men naked in front of
the fireplace it happens
sometimes sometimes sometimes the role
will call for that and you got to get
into it it's like method acting you know
what i mean [ __ ] you got to make sure
you're kind of rocking up a little bit
and like you're really into this
but [ __ ]
oliver reed was evidently he was a
[ __ ] handful in real life and
everybody loved him he said he was a
[ __ ] great guy oh real intelligent
there's all kinds of interviews with him
on talk shows
he's a real good interview and you're
like man i could [ __ ] get drunk with
that dude
you know he comes across very
mild-mannered and [ __ ] real
intelligent but you know that that's a
front
that that dude gets drunk and he's
[ __ ] wild all right
oh yeah you can totally you can totally
see he got drunk and just said he got
drunk here in the united states and said
[ __ ] it it took all his clothes off and
just stand there at the bar and it just
walked out as one does as one would do
when you're in i mean i've never done
that walk down the street naked
so the cops [ __ ] jumping
[Laughter]
and they're like you're oliver reed he's
like he has them oliver they [ __ ]
just put his clothes back on too you
know who i am yeah yeah they just put
his clothes back on take him to the
hotel
okay oliver reed
we know how to deal with the likes of
you
well yeah i think i think you know
he's on tour he's going he he's going to
america to [ __ ] fly his trade
and uh he's going to get wild you know
because he's not at home so he's going
to abuse it that's what i that's how i
well the thing about it though i mean
at least as far as my perception went
was like in the uk i mean
they
drinking is much more like i'm not
saying drinking isn't part of the
culture in the us because it is
but drinking is much more like
normalized i guess in the uk so it's
just kind of like people doing drunk ash
[ __ ] they're just kind of like yep
all right well that's that's just how
was it it's okay that's that's just all
right yeah so i kind of feel like
everyone has stories like that so we
just we just deal with it and we move on
now we have a new person this is a new
person dan michael says what is she
drinking if it has alcohol in it i'll
like her better you must be new here
yeah are you new here right yeah because
this is our side track show i mean we
get drunk on the regular show too but
our sidetrack show
yes this has
copious amounts of vodka in it and this
is my third one yeah of this size see
this is damn i need to watch more oliver
reed [ __ ] movies he sounds
interesting yeah oliver reed was the
[ __ ] he was the [ __ ]
um she also asked wasn't he the dad in
burnt office yes yes indeed yes
and honestly burnt offerings
i is one of my favorite haunted house
movies of all time and he kind of played
it it's so good he kind of plays a nice
guy in that although he does remember it
possesses him and he almost kills his
son yeah
and so he had that he
well
he has this ability to make you think
he's getting ready to [ __ ] snap on
you
and so i think he was like really good
for that role right to be honest with
you because the whole thing i don't know
like if you guys have read the novel
which i would recommend it's by robert
marasco
and um
in that one it's kind of like what the
house does
the house
much like in the shining i guess yeah it
feeds
on people like that's how it restores
itself it's just like it's so it kind of
like targets your weaknesses
and feeds on that yeah
so
that's kind of like what happens with
his character in that movie
and so i think he was a good choice
because he kind of comes across as
normal-ish in the beginning but a little
bit
like you could see how
something
could target that because he was very
like skeptical he's like nah we're not
[ __ ] doing this type of [ __ ]
and then
but it like really took advantage
and he had a real good voice too
and he was always kind of had this like
a simmering
kind of
potential for violence
in his [ __ ] voice and uh
it was like he's holding back
some whoop ass
and that he you know is or murder he was
like
in some ways he was kind of like a
[ __ ] evil version
of james earl jones in a certain ways
there was kind of he kind of had a james
earl jones style voice just listen to
him he's good and then in the brood he
plays a doctor as a psychologist who's
getting people to kind of exteriorize
all their damn emotions and remember
that [ __ ] yeah
and he's in his
he he was calling them uh workshops like
therapy workshops and he's doing it
in this [ __ ] seminar place it really
brought me back to california down to
cote de caza back in the 70s when i was
a kid going to those horse shows and
they had those places set up they'd rent
them out and i'd go play in them and
they'd be empty it was like an outside
movie is that like just like what they
showed
like these little yeah
well they were and they were like
outside
movie theaters slash
auditoriums and there'd be a bunches of
them and you could walk from one to the
next and they they were renting them out
and you could have them for like
business meetings and seminars
and had them next to all the horse show
places and i go play in them with some
of the other kids
and [ __ ] we ran in one time and
[ __ ] it was it was filled with dudes
with the [ __ ] chalkboard and the
[ __ ] dude let's get out of here we
ran like that they all the whole
audience like 100 people started
laughing was businessman we're doing
some raw food up in here
yeah that's [ __ ] funny
sorry that's like a 70s [ __ ] right there
yeah
so he's having his [ __ ] work seven
his therapy with seminars up there and
he's creating he got this one woman to
create monsters
and it's just [ __ ] well see i feel
like cronenberg well yeah he was kind of
like tapping into the zeitgeist of the
70s i guess yeah which 70s that was very
much like kind of a carryover of the
whole new age situation
and you kind of had all these self-help
groups we're trying to like
self-actualize we're trying to do this
on the other so i like that he took that
one step further where he's like we have
this group
where
we're basically taking your emotions and
exteriorizing them
and
his
magnum opus i guess you could say
was this woman who was able to
exteriorize her emotions into actual
babies yeah that actually like grew up
into children but were like rage
children yeah
i wish i had thought of that i really
wish i had thought of that somebody goes
wait hold on james earl jones was the
good one
[Laughter]
oh there's something about oliver reed
oliver reed seemed like he was more
prone to violence than james earl jones
did james earl jones always seemed kind
of like grandfather type yeah he seemed
pretty chill he was like like he was uh
gravitas and [ __ ] he never really seemed
violent even when he was doing thulsome
doom he never really he was not doing it
didn't seem like physical violence even
though he cut that woman's head off he
was just using his [ __ ] meme magic
his voice and [ __ ] you know
now i cut someone's head off but you
know i'm not like threatening or
anything yeah
when you saw him later on you know
as
when he was up in his [ __ ] temple of
doom
temple of power
but um
no
oliver reed looked like he was about
half drunk and was getting ready to slap
you that's what he did
that's what he seemed i mean you guys if
you guys have not seen burnt offerings
man that's like one of my favorite
haunted house movies i think legend of
hell house like is my favorite from the
70s
burnt offerings might be my second
favorite
yeah now that's oliver reed and karen
black yeah karen black and burgess
meredith and betty davis and betty davis
yeah
now
michael kane i liked him too he was
[ __ ] great actor a lot of good movies
the island which is forgotten i got a
copy of that [ __ ] we did a review of
that you know the island yeah about the
[ __ ] pirates
all right
um
the island was [ __ ] great
and uh [ __ ] the hand oliver stone
man i love the hand and
the more times i see it the more
appreciation i have of how
brilliant it is now michael caine
people might know him now as you know
alfred from batman
me growing up i didn't see him like that
he was another one it was kind of like
kind of like some drunk [ __ ]
getting ready to slap you
[Laughter]
michael king which could also describe
you yeah
what's he [ __ ] you
pow
yeah yeah yeah although you slapped me
i'm slapping you right back yeah i
didn't [ __ ] yeah
i'd be like pat yeah [ __ ] michael
caine michael kane was seemed morton's a
lot more unstable when he was playing a
maniac
oh yeah he seemed a lot more unstable
sweating did [ __ ]
yeah he was [ __ ] and for those of you
because i know that um the person that
asked what i was drinking is new here
yeah um
since you're new here
last year or the year before on
halloween
tom dressed up as michael caine's
character from the hand yeah i got that
out he still has the wig
and he still has the hand it's right
back there
hands right here it was like right it
was on his shoulder the whole time
that was like oh that was my favorite i
loved that so much got a michael caine
wig yeah you do
i mean technically it's a willy wonka
wig but it looked exactly like michael
caine's hair in that [ __ ] movie you
had the jumpsuit everything it was
amazing amazing i loved that
honestly tila's gonna watch burnt offers
tonight
she's seen it before but she said she
wanted to re-watch it yeah honestly
i never get tired of that movie yeah
what like everybody know i love haunted
house movies yeah um i know there's a
[ __ ] ton of them most of them suck but
there's a lot of really good ones burnt
offerings is so [ __ ] good man and the
book is good too
yeah
teresa says that burnt offerings is on
amazon prime for 3.99 okay and i would
[ __ ] i would uh he's on shutter for a
while i don't know
if you've already seen burnt offerings
i'd [ __ ] i'd for the 399 you could
probably see the brood
and that's got that's got him in it yeah
i wonder where that's at yeah no oliver
reed not like that's got oliver reed in
it
the brood i think you'd like that one
too
i mean probably better because you
haven't really seen that
yeah it's cronenberg
and i kind of feel like burnt offerings
is free on youtube evidently not for
everybody they're going there and they
said it's not there
i mean if you have a vpn maybe but
i don't know is it
i thought it was on shutter but it
the thing about shutter is that like
sometimes they'll add stuff and then
it'll just be on there for like a month
or two and then it'll disappear because
they only have the rights for so long
but
because it was on shutter for a little
while because i think i rewatched it
because i was like oh look burnt
offerings and i watched it again just
because
but
i don't know
teresa says i've not seen her on youtube
yeah i kind of feel like that maybe i
don't know
i don't know but
yeah maybe it's blocked in the u.s for
copyright reasons it's free in the
german says it's free in the uk on
youtube okay well maybe that's why we
can't see it yeah maybe that's why
blocked in the u.s like if you don't
have shutter like if you have shutter
check that first
if you don't then check some other [ __ ]
i don't really know it i don't think
it's on tubie or anything like that but
i have to pay to rent it but it's good i
mean if you like haunted house [ __ ] and
you like 70s [ __ ] yeah i mean burnt
offerings is like really really good
all-star cast man all-star cast
um michael caine was a badass in get
carter and harry brown i haven't seen
harry brown but get carter was like
really really good
i mean you know michael kane [ __ ] man
he's like [ __ ] awesome
what's matter i'm hungry you hungry yeah
you wanna like you wanna you feel like
you wanna like [ __ ]
victor says the free movie on youtube is
burnt offering and it looks like a new
low budget movie oh okay yeah okay so
don't be okay so that's the thing
don't be fooled don't be fooled burnt
offerings with this s with an s on the
end yeah it's from
1977 or 1978. yeah
oliver reed is in it yeah karen black is
in it yep
uh betty davis is in it yep burgess
meredith is in it yeah so if that's not
the movie that you're watching then
that's not the right one
yeah got a big old tall skinny
[ __ ] driving a hearse
oh my god the first time i saw that
movie i saw it at a
sleepover
when i was 13. i think i was 13.
and i saw a sleepover
and
we were all in this and we um the girl's
house who's uh whose house it was at
her dad
was a heart surgeon and he had this
massive like mansion and i mean it
seemed like a mansion to me because like
i grew up in a [ __ ] trailer park so
you know but it had like a big [ __ ]
marble staircase all that [ __ ]
and all these kind of like little back
hallways servant staircases all that
kind of [ __ ]
so
i was doing i was having a sleepover at
this place and one of the movies we
rented was burnt offerings
and we were watching it in this little
room
and
that chauffeur
comes on the screen
every single girl in that room got up
and we're like nope and like ran in like
all different directions
we're all like 13 year old girls we're
like yep nope too scary too scary
but you know
but i still remember that and i still
remember like how see
i still remember like how [ __ ]
awesome and scary that movie was
i wonder where that new person went
maybe he was just kind of like nope not
having it
yeah burnt offerings on prime video
costs 3.99 it's worth it though i mean i
feel like maybe i don't know if you'll
if y'all feel the same but i kind of
feel like it's worth reading i'm just
saying
1976. okay so it's older than i thought
it was
well hugo only now just showed up yeah
we're already on part two
and we're already like kind of blaster
one says hey guys i'm new
wow we got new people yep oh my god what
are you guys in for
and they show up now when we're already
like [ __ ] wasted at this point yeah
yeah dan michael says i'm still here
what if you guys review satan's children
75 or circa it's either the worst or
best home movie ever oh i haven't seen
it never heard of it i might have seen
that that sounds very familiar but i'm
going to write it down because that
sounds like some [ __ ] that i would that
i would watch
you know what i'm still mad can i say
that i'm still mad
that we haven't got to do
devil's reign
do you remember that one with william
shatner oh yeah yeah yeah and like
[ __ ] what's his ass was in it antoine
levitt not
he was a he was a technical consultant
yeah
um
john travolta was in that [ __ ] too is he
not i think so he didn't have a speaking
role
i keep it and honestly it's funny every
time i put it in the patreon poll
i remember that devil's reign has an
exclamation point at the end does it the
devil's reign has an exclamation point
god damn it yeah
so one of these days i'm going to do
that move maybe we'll just do it anyway
cool i'm buzzed too by the way okay well
that's good yeah so are we like i said
this is my
i don't know i've had so much
it's my third one and this is of this
size and like i said it's like a lot of
a lot of bucket
all right
um
[Music]
all right so yeah we have to do that
yeah hugo says i've been working
afternoons i've been missing half a show
i know i'm sorry about that
i mean you know this is our friday
nights it's fun race with the devil is
great we did
a review
of
race with the devil and the car yeah we
did those both on one show i think we
did yeah i'm pretty sure i remember the
car but i don't remember race for this
race with the devil was the one that
those families or those friends or
whatever and they were in the winnebago
yeah do you remember the winnebago and
then they were like getting chased by
the yeah yeah yeah
yeah we did like vehicular horror yeah
double feature like we did race with the
devil and we did the car
yeah uh on one thing the car is the
better one out of them all
right it's weird because i kind of feel
like race with the devil is the better
regarded
yeah but the car was but i remember the
car more yeah the cars were a lot more
memorable
just because
it's a good monster movie i mean it's
not good
objective for what it is but it's still
like memorable yeah i kind of feel like
i liked it
and that was another one
you know
in the set like duel yeah where they
never showed it like that yeah it was
kind of like it reminded me of like
richard matheson's duel or steven
spielberg's duel if you want to be like
the movie adaptation about it but where
they never showed
whatever it was that was in the car or
the truck that was chasing them
and that's kind of made it scarier just
saying
danny rolling ghostface is talking about
the living dead at the manchester morgue
uh yes i've seen that uh but not for a
very long time great italian zombie film
from 1974. i remember liking that a lot
but i haven't seen it for many years so
i will have to
rewatch that at some point i'm sure i'll
get around to like reviewing that at
some point
uh the brood you can run it on amazon
prime for 2.99
oh [ __ ] yeah so there you go
[ __ ] that always that almost makes me
want to watch it again yeah well we have
it on blu-ray
remember oh that's right we do don't we
got it on blu-ray honestly like i said
if i'm sober enough later on tonight i
want to watch some more disaster movies
no no yeah we do nature run amok movies
i want to see zardoz again
zardoz
if we do okay i want that if we do
zardoz yeah
we have to do a matinee on that yeah oh
yeah we gotta do a show one because zara
does
what seriously
what drugs
were they on
it's the same dude that did excalibur
all right yeah i know and
i want to see it again i want to see if
i can get more out of it
i remember it being almost kind of like
cross between excalibur and barbarella
remember barbarella [ __ ] yeah
barbarella is like fun actually yeah it
was kind of like that
but it makes like about 50 percent less
sense i think maybe it makes more sense
now maybe i just wasn't looking at the
right way i want to see i think it does
though i like i remember because i
remember seeing it when i was younger
and then we saw it a couple years ago
and then i was kind of like
man this makes even less sense than i
remember it making yeah
and i'm pretty sure i was sober both
times i watched it
but
that's some crazy [ __ ]
you have like you have to admire though
going into a movie with that premise
because what is even the premise of
zardoz
well okay there's a baby he's thinking
about it all right it's you have it's a
big giant head well that was one part of
it floating through the sky
you have a big giant head floating
through the sky vomiting up a bunch of
guns and giving it to these savage
[ __ ] who are raping and killing
people and it's saying guns are guns are
good the penis is evil
yeah okay so then it turns out that the
head is flies back to the when he gets
in it flies back to a [ __ ] a real
protected area where they had people
that
were bored with life i don't think they
had even had sex did they
no they didn't have sex and they were
immortal right they were immortal i
think but i can't remember him
had gone some of them had gone kind of
catatonic
and somehow his presence there got them
to re-enjoy life again
that's how i remember but i want to see
it again so the way i interpret it now
is that
they were a civilization of people that
had become immortal and kindness and
kind of
superior they're a real intelligent
they're like blase about everything yeah
blase about everything
so they had a program to send these
heads out and vomit up guns to get
people to kill other people as one does
so they would not overpopulate i guess
and threaten them in their city
is that what it was
oh maybe that's what i think it i think
they were holding the population in
check i guess that is true
because remember they didn't have any
defenses that's true
so i i i want to see it again that seems
like kind of an elaborate plan just
saying yeah they were godlike remember
yeah they can age a person as punishment
if anybody questioned anything they
punted they'd age them i want to see it
again
dermot says wasn't barbarella an italian
movie from 1968. duran duran yeah um
yeah was it italian yeah well it was did
it was it dino dude
i think maybe yeah and that's where
duran durand with ds at the end that's
where the band got their name from from
the valley's
yeah he was played by milo o'shea the
irish actor yeah and they had jane fonda
in it and scantily clad jane fonda
floating around
and wasn't that the movie that odd that
had the orgasmatron was it called an
orgasmatron yeah they go in and have an
orgasm
yeah she had sex with the angel
that's right pygar yeah
and the pygar was played by what the
[ __ ] was that actor's name
i remember him because he was in space
mutiny space mutiny this the terrible
south african
sci-fi movie that was
one of the best episodes of mst
except he was obviously much older yeah
at this point uh because he was like
super hot when he was younger yeah
not so much when he was older but you
know what i'm saying
uh you know
they're all like popping popcorn
yeah
uh karen said yeah john philip law thank
you that was his name the thing was the
thing with barbarella and danger
diabolique that's right
yeah that was also an mst episode the
thing with barbarella is that barbaria
had jane fonda in it when she was
probably at the zenith of her [ __ ]
hotness
and they were kind of i remember there
was some brief nudity in it yeah but it
did kind of
i remember it kind of holding out the
promise of maybe this would be an
x-rated porn flick but it never really
would it never was but you made you
think that it was it looked it it kind
of
it made a 15 year old boy think that
porn was going to happen remember that
this porn gonna happen it's just they're
gonna knock that [ __ ] down this time oh
he's going to get that but it never
would happen see that's how they got
teenage boys to watch movies back in the
old days right that's how they did it
baby
porn's going to break out
at any minute she's going to take so you
have to keep paying attention gonna take
and so like 15 year old boys be like all
right
she's gonna take that [ __ ] off anymore
all right titties yeah that's right this
is good where's the bush okay yeah all
right that's what was happening it never
[ __ ] happened that's how i remembered
that movie i've only seen it once and i
remember it being boring and not really
understanding the plot i remember
certain things happened but i was like
this is it it was a weird 60s lsd
inspired
sci-fi pre-star trek seemed like it was
like star trek was high tech compared to
that [ __ ]
that's how i kind of feel like everybody
back then was just on drugs and so
right
and honestly like you know i grew up in
the 70s so i get like i wasn't on drugs
obviously because i was a kid
but
you just saw this stuff that adults were
making yeah adults who were on drugs
so you just kind of like just you
accepted it it was hokey she she came
from a space
fairing civilization they were kind of
like the police
but
they were peaceful and didn't have
weapons
they gave her a bow i think out of
anything she said she has
if i remember crying she had a bow
she has a [ __ ] flying saucer a
spaceship and a bow that's it
and then they send her out to [ __ ] do
this difficult [ __ ] mission
with no weapons she's just gonna get it
done just by pure love and [ __ ] she's
gonna [ __ ] her way through the mission
which she does but you don't see it it
works
but you don't see it
that was how i remember barbarella
she [ __ ] her way through it and you
didn't get to see her [ __ ] way
through it that's that's that's how i
need to see it again that's how i
remembered it it's been a long time yeah
i kind of feel like the movie because i
was a big uh back in the 80s when i was
you know a child and a teenager i was
really into duran duran so because
they'd got their name from barbarella of
course i had to kind of go like watch
all that [ __ ] so i kind of got all
versed in that
um so i but i haven't seen it in a very
long time dj maniac says danger
diabolique is a fantastic film and did
not need to be mistied um
i would argue that most films could be
mistied it's fine i'm not really worried
about it because they've done like
rifftrax has done good movies too it
doesn't bother me
but
i will argue that that is actually one
of the better movies that they've done
that is actually a a decent
movie and john phillip law looks really
good in it in his little black
sleek [ __ ]
yeah dermot mentions the little snapping
dolls i remember the snapping dolls from
[ __ ] barbaros they had a little
[ __ ] shiny teeth and the little
wind-up dolls are coming after and she
did get bit a couple times but i
remember but i remember that it was just
kind of it was
barbarella was not meant to be taken
seriously it was it was kind of campy it
was a campy 60s drug movie
it really morning
it was a lot of movies yeah and it was
[ __ ]
flower power it was that's what it was a
flower power movie it didn't make any
goddamn sense
and it was almost about more about
fashion they were dressing up cool
clothes in it
and uh it was kind of like flash gordon
but nowhere near as cool fast garden was
a lot better i mean flash gordon is like
an eyegasm yeah when you see it on
blu-ray on a good tv it looks really
good man it's like it's so beautiful i
just i love the like the look of flash i
saw it two or three times in the theater
when i was a kid i [ __ ] loved it i
liked it as much as star wars
and then it came out on
came out on tv on cable like the year
after and it looked like [ __ ] on
television which gave it a real bad rep
but if you see it on if you see it on
blu-ray on a good tv
flash gordon look badass it's gorgeous
just really high quality costumes and
stuff and it uh looks just like those
old comic books
see that's what it's kind of sad because
i kind of feel like i don't this isn't a
problem nowadays but
people of our generation
i kind of feel like there were there
were movies that came out in the 70s and
80s
and for a long time you kind of thought
oh this was like i love this movie but
it was like shitty looking or whatever
and then you see it later on this is why
i'm a big fan of like watching stuff
that you loved growing up and like
watching it again when you're an adult
now because
honestly back when you just had like vhs
or like shitty ass tvs yeah everything
looked like the balls it just looked
really really bad
and so now that everything's been like
lovingly restored yeah i was kind of
like oh my god
competent people made this movie look at
those shots look at those costumes and
it's like when you saw it back in the
80s you just thought it was some like
throwaway piece of garbage because it
looked like ass yeah that's that's
that's what happened to flash gordon
most people didn't see in the theaters
they saw it on tv and it looked like
that's terrible yeah but yeah it did in
in in the theaters it looks [ __ ]
great it looked better than star wars to
me
i mean it looked different you could
definitely tell it was a different style
the different the color
the colors
palette was different the different it
was not supposed to be realistic it was
fantasy but it was just like the
the the the the flash gordon cereals and
the [ __ ]
color front page comics crazy colors
which that's what
that's what flash gordon was crazy
colors weird psychedelic [ __ ] [ __ ] that
didn't make sense ray guns went down
[ __ ] spikes on the front of them and
they just got it right that's what it
was
and um
see flash gordon [ __ ] in hd on a
[ __ ] good television [ __ ] badass
it looks really nice see it [ __ ]
slightly choked out you're supposed to
be a little bit [ __ ] high watching
that [ __ ] well i kind of feel like that
was a given like back in the 70s like
well everyone's gonna be like at least a
little bit high like watching this yeah
you know yeah and you're not supposed to
take it seriously it's 1920s style
it's good though
i mean can we just say though i was
watching
i don't know why i just 20s or 30s
30s 20s yeah 20s
oh it may have been well it might have
started in the 20s i think it was 20s
yeah the flash gordon series it might
have started in the late 20s maybe it
was before it was pre-haze code yeah so
they had drugs and sex and everything in
the tv series when was hayes code 34 i
think so yeah
my blue ray up it comes with like a
first uh i think three episodes or four
episodes of the original uh
uh flash gordon television series and
it's big satanic [ __ ] statues with
drip women
semi-nude women dripping off the hands
of the damn satan statue forearms on it
talking about ming's [ __ ]
definitely [ __ ] into his daughter
definitely [ __ ] they're giving drinks
drinks and special potions to each other
and [ __ ] they're totally hedonistic and
this is 12 20 30s or 20s it's
it was they were dirty by their dirty
[ __ ]
some of that [ __ ] would not have been
appropriate even for the 70s
uh definitely not the 50s definitely
well the 50s
no [ __ ] that i mean you could get away
with a lot for the 70s
and you could get away with a lot in the
20s yeah you could get away in the 70s
you couldn't get away with some of that
[ __ ] in the 80s but they were making sex
and drugs and violence yeah and the same
scene i kind of feel like 70s you could
get away with almost anything almost
yeah
because i've seen some [ __ ] that came
out in the 70s and i'm just kind of like
well i actually i heard guys from the
industry talking about this is that some
of the [ __ ] that they were doing in the
70s was illegal
that you weren't supposed to do that but
they did it anyway and no one ever
checked them so they would they would do
it again i believe it because it had to
do with complaints and how much time
they had and and evidently the people in
the like the people that did all the
ratings and all the lawsuits type [ __ ]
really didn't give a [ __ ]
as long as it was
as long as the there wasn't a public
outcry they really didn't care too much
what you did
yeah that was that was the uh
that was kind of the vibe that i got
yeah we'll put the movie out as long as
no one complains it'll be all right then
right okay that's there was a lot of
that
so i kind of feel like so there was
something in the 70s everyone was too
coked up to complain yeah and some of
that [ __ ] was i guess
basically
pedo type stuff and
it was they got away with it like i said
a little uncomfortable nowadays uh gotta
say to watch was that pretty baby and
[ __ ] blue lagoon blue lagoon was a
little kind of pedo pedo-ish it was and
honestly even when i saw it in the 80s i
was kind of like
yeah but nobody complained it was weird
it was a hit movie like i wasn't gonna
complain about it but i was just kind of
like oh yeah okay problematic
but yeah that there was kind of like
[ __ ] like that going on and
not saying that's good i'm just saying
they got away with a lot of [ __ ] back
then that you would not get away with
nowadays
hugo says the flash gordon series for
the silver screen was made in the 40s i
don't think it
okay well the one 1940 1940 okay
i could have swore i think the comic
books even predated that though
well yeah the comic books are created
like 30s or 20s
they've been around for a long time and
the ones that i have i don't know if
that came from 1940 or 1930. they were
talking
but it looked like early talkies and i
don't know if it was
it could have been made for tv no tv
so it must have been they were very
short they were only about
15 minutes long
the uh the the
the little episodes that that came on
the blu-ray
they were like they were yeah they're so
they had them they had them cut together
into a featurette but it was
i think they were only 15 or 20 minutes
long
each one
i think i had to go back and look which
is hilarious because people talk about
people nowadays having like a short
attention span yeah i was like do you
guys know how short the movies were back
then yeah they're real short movies back
then were like an hour well they were
like yeah but they played movies before
the movie well they had shorts and like
then a couple of movies right yeah you
know you'd kind of go you'd pay a nickel
and you'd hang out at the [ __ ] movie
theater all day
louie says hey louie showed up what's up
louie i'm old enough to remember when
there were only three networks i am too
yep um
when i was a kid yeah we had
nbc abc cbs
and also pbs but that was like local
yeah and i remember
when
fox 35 started it wasn't 35 everywhere
that was like a little thing but when
fox started
that was like a big huge deal because it
was like a fifth channel what's up louie
and
when it first started all they showed
was old tom and jerry cartoons
and samford and sun and jefferson's
reruns
that's all they showed
uh yeah dermot
says hayes could start in 1934. oh i got
it right all right i did say 1934.
goddamn i'm smarter than i thought uh we
used to watch the old flash gordon shows
on saturday morning kids tv in the 70s
yeah they were they were less than a
half hour long
for what i remember yeah i kind of feel
like everything back then was like super
short
super short
i was pretty sure some of that stuff
predated haze to the code though
well it might have because some of it
was kind of like kind of dirty yeah
well not dirty but better they could
maybe skirt it in some weird ways
they must been pushing it
because when the haze code came along it
kind of like ruined everything they're
like well
you could show like some
[ __ ] before that because there was like
some pretty scandalous by the way you
know by the air you know standards of
the era
uh prior to that like in movies and
stuff
and then after that it's like well
we can't even show like they couldn't
even like suggest
any sexual anything they couldn't like
suggest
any kind of like horror gore or anything
they couldn't do anything like that some
of that flash gordon stuff is suggestive
yeah it is yeah it is
but they somehow got around it i mean
some of those outfits were dead
were
almost nudity it's like
they're wearing leotards and unitards
but they're very [ __ ] tight and you
can
you can see you know i mean it's like
they're almost nude
and then there's might be something on
it but you know what i mean you can
uh okay it wouldn't wouldn't shock like
a normal person today at all you know
what i mean a bikini is more revealing
but you're thinking this is 40s or 30s
this is pretty [ __ ] yeah i mean this
is suggestive
yeah not for real life but for
for them yeah that was suggestive you
know it's uh
i think they were kind of lenient on
some of it
i guess it's all just in the eye of the
beholder
they must have talked to their way
around some of it well just like
anything anytime anybody like brings
down any kind of like rules yeah
like you know we can't show this that
the other people are gonna try to like
[ __ ] find some loopholes yeah you
know what i'm saying so it's like yeah
we're gonna like show
nudity kind of but what they have like
nude colored
unitards on so they're not naked they
have clothes on but you can still like
imagine
because they don't leave anything to the
imagination it's like you can still see
you know
all the contours of their body and stuff
so it's like
you know
it's not like we're showing it but we're
still kind of
not showing it that's how they got
around that [ __ ] i'm getting hungry
jenny want to go ahead and uh
call it a night
i mean i'm having a good time but if you
if you want to stay down for longer you
can but
but you're not going to you're you're
going to leave are you going to make me
some food yeah you're going to be part
of i got to pack that stuff up and then
we'll get some food
are you going to make some more we've
been on for five hours you should make
some more potatoes okay
uh tammy says i also made the pumpkin
soup last week from our cooking oh okay
yeah what'd you think of that
she said really good okay
man i love that pumpkin soup yeah we
didn't make it this year but we made it
last year yeah like for that's like an
appetizer didn't come across pumpkins
you drink it in mugs yeah like
didn't come across
i love pumpkin soup honestly you can
take that pumpkin soup and modify it
with a bunch of indian spices and add
chicken to it to make a [ __ ] chicken
chicken pumpkin curry too which we've
also made they made that last year yeah
put raisins in it or [ __ ] cran or
dried cranberries
whatever you want so good
oh my goodness yeah
camp guy said i had leftovers today yeah
so did we and honestly i'm gonna have
some
more leftovers right now
yeah all right so
tom's getting
agitated yeah i'm getting hungry
getting [ __ ] started
so we're gonna have to go yeah but thank
you guys for hanging out with us this
friday evening this black friday
and we will see you guys on sunday
not sure what movie we'll be talking
about but we might watch some like
[ __ ] disaster [ __ ] tonight i'll talk
about that on sunday but we'll be back
on sunday afternoon so everybody come
back and hang out with us thank you for
hanging out with us on friday night
thank you for all your super chats
and all the conversation we will see you
guys on
sunday afternoon
good night